[Music]
obviously we've spent a pretty good
amount of time around here talking about
the assault on free speech on college
campuses as I've said before I believe
that this assault on free speech is one
of the biggest problems we face today as
we are breeding a generation of young
people who won't be equipped to use
logic and reason in their own arguments
when they graduate to the real world the
university's misguided use of safe
spaces and trigger warnings coupled with
violent protests and D platforming or
shouting down speakers is actually
robbing many of these students of
literally the most important thing that
they can learn in college the ability to
think for themselves instead of
graduating as fully equipped adults
ready to fight for what they believe in
because they know what they believe in
they are being coddled like children who
might crumble at the mere hearing of an
idea that challenges them this inability
to debate ideas is leaking out of the
universities and into society at large
celebrities spent all day on Twitter
ranting and raving about topics that
they don't understand at all
comedians some of whom I know personally
and really liked have become the
screeching lunatics that they're
supposed to be making fun of politicians
talk a lot but don't actually do a lot
and the rest of us are left here trying
to make some sense of what's going on a
great example of this is the title 9
Fiasco which took root on college
campuses over the past few years title 9
is part of the Education Act of 1972
which states that no person in the
United States shall on the basis of sex
be excluded from participation in be
denied the benefits of or be subjected
to discrimination under any education
program or activity receiving federal
financial assistance well that sounds
pretty good right what we should be
going for here is an even playing field
of equal opportunity title 9 doesn't
guarantee equal outcome which is where
hard work perseverance and sometimes
luck come into play but it does
guarantee that whether you are a man or
a woman you won't be discriminated on
because of your sex this straightforward
law of equal opportunity changed under
the Obama administration which in 2011
and 2014
issued new guidelines on how schools
should deal with cases of sexual assault
on campus while I believe that Obama's
intentions were good the law in effect
circumvented our system of due process
the Obama administration's policy used
the preponderance of evidence standard
in cases of sexual assault
not the beyond-a-reasonable-doubt
standard which reduces the burden of
proof on anyone accused of sexual
assault this was a subtle but powerful
change in how we litigate these cases of
sexual assault on campus and some would
argue an outright violation of the
accused constitutional rights that seem
to boss
Trump's education secretary recently
rescinded these obama mandates and
judging by the celebrity and comedian
critics out there Trump and DeVos were
not only anti-woman
but suddenly pro rape as well my friend
and former guest christina hoff sommers
wrote an excellent piece in the journal
of higher education explaining why
removing the obama guidelines was
actually a win for due process and the
constitution an article i shared with
some of the famous people I saw ranting
about Trump's pro rape policy of course
nobody responded will link to
Christina's article below so that you
can read that for yourself to unpack
title 9 I'll be talking to author and
professor Laura Kipnis today as we
discuss her own story of how title 9 has
affected her both personally and
professionally laura has been right in
the middle of the title 9 firestorm and
our friends at learn Liberty have sent
her our way this week knowing what
you're talking about is a lot harder
than just screaming about how you feel
about something but a good education
taught me that it's usually worth the
effort
[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
is author of unwanted advances sexual
paranoia comes to campus as well as a
professor in the Department of radio
television and film at Northwestern
University
Laura Kipnis welcome to the Rubin report
thank you hi hi I have had a roughly if
I had to add it all up a gajillion
requests to have you on okay so I feel
like we're gonna clean up a lot of stuff
here related let's try yeah related to
title 9 I did my little direct message
my preamble sort of giving a vague
explanation of title 9 mm-hm you sort of
got in the mix on this thing when you
wrote a piece in The Chronicles of
Higher Education in 2015 which I want to
get to that and your whole story related
to all of that but first I thought could
you just give me a basic explanation of
what title 9 is and then how it changed
during the Obama administration okay I
should start out and say that it was
never my goal in life to become an
expert on title 9 but as you might have
said in the intro I was brought up on
title 9 complaints and at the time I had
no idea what this was you know I thought
it had something to do with women's
sports so the brief backstory is that in
2011 the Department of Education under
Obama expanded title 9 which had covered
gender equity in higher education
meaning like equal funding for sports
teams and that sort of thing and they
expanded it to include sexual misconduct
because the idea was that you can't have
gender equity if students particularly
women's students are you know fearful
for their safety or are being assaulted
you know or harassed or that kind of
thing so you know it's a it's it's a
good goal but they issued these things
called Dear Colleague letters that were
guidance to institutions of higher
learning that got federal funding and
threatened that if the schools didn't
comply with these very vague guidelines
that their federal funding could be
withdrawn and you know most schools get
you know tons of their funding from the
government in research grants and that
kind of thing so all campuses were
required
offices and officers and implement these
this guidance and it had to do creating
processes for sexual misconduct
complaints but also dictated things like
the standard of proof that would have to
be used in these adjudications and the
standard was what's called preponderance
of evidence and that's a hugely
controversial thing because it basically
means is 50/50 plus a feather and the
process also has been I mean as I
learned having gone through it behind
closed doors so none of this is out in
the open or transparent and so you have
more and more people getting caught up
in in these sort of kangaroo court
situations both undergrads mostly male
students who get accused of having
non-consensual sex usually in drunken
you know sexual encounters that somebody
later decides was not consensual but
also professors increasingly so what
happened was after I got brought up on
these complaints I wrote a second
article and I got brought up for writing
an essay about you know the kind of
increasing vulnerability of students and
it was called sexual paranoid comes to a
khadeem yeah I think I think maybe we
should pause there because you get me
all out there so let's just whittle away
some of that right so first of all I
think a certain amount of people would
would be listening to this and thinking
wait a minute how can a university lower
the expectation of what evidences to
prove someone guilty of something if
it's supposed to be you're innocent
until proven guilty how can how can an
university have a expectation that's
lower than that how does that even how
does that even make sense I mean what's
the actual rationale there
well the rationale is that they're
following this federal guidance but you
know what happened what the federal
guidance seems to be in conflict with
the Constitution well so one of the
things I learned is you don't actually
have constitutional rights at a private
university so there's how this stuff is
handled differs between public
institutions and private schools and
private schools can do what they want so
they're in a more contractual relation
with students and you know a lot of the
information on this is
only coming out because these cases are
going to civil court
so like students who've been accused and
think they've been railroaded are suing
the schools and that's how we learn
what's going on otherwise nobody would
know
so in effect these these edicts come
through from the administration it's on
you know now the the burden of evidence
is suddenly on the accused in a bizarre
way and it really never bubbled up until
some of the men in this case started
taking civil action because they were
either falsely accused or they felt that
they were falsely accused her wanted to
fight yeah or there are no standards of
evidence and so that was the kind of
thing I learned from going through the
process so I was accused of say creating
a hostile environment and I said to the
title 9 investigators what how do you
know I mean it's a or I was creating a
chilling effect on the student body and
I should we should explain that those so
your your 2015 article let's just
explain what that was and how it got you
a diet water before every ok jumping for
it I wrote an article called sexual
paranoia strikes a khadeem for the
Chronicle of Higher Education because
they asked me to write something about
campus sexual politics because I was
known I guess have been known as
something of maybe a contrarian feminist
and I'm written about social politics a
lot so I said ok and I kind of thought
nobody read the Chronicle of Higher
Education you know and so I've wrote in
a kind of ironic maybe um you know I had
some fun with it
and I do lean toward irony and so first
there was a protest march on campus by
students carrying mattresses and pillows
you know like a reference to the
Columbia student accusing me of
fostering or supporting rape culture I
guess and then I was found out I was
brought up on these title 9 components
but so I never found out precisely what
I was charged with because there isn't
such a thing as due process in these
situations right so to be clear you
write this piece and as you're saying it
was kind of tongue-in-cheek but with the
expertise that you have be serious but
with an ironic tone I would say yeah
yeah so you write this piece and then
your bra
on these charges but what does you
writing this piece have to do with
anything how does that yeah become
within the jurisdiction of title 9 well
it should not have been and so it is a
question mark why the university allowed
the case to go forward because there is
some sort of provision in the New York
Holly letter that says nothing here
should be construed to impinge on
freedom of speech or academic freedom
but nevertheless I mean what does happen
what's happened is what you would call
mission creep in these situations where
the code has been stretched to include
such things as writing an essay and as I
later found out I mean all sorts of kind
of micro behaviors that somebody might
take offense at so in my case I had
written a couple of paragraphs about a
another professor on the campus so I
didn't know but it was public
information that he'd been accused of
sexual misconduct so I made reference to
that case so I was accused of
retaliating which is a big thing in
title 9 you cannot mostly people cannot
speak about the charges against them
because if they speak about them they
might be brought up on more complaints
for retaliating so I was charged with
retaliation even though I wasn't the
person who'd been involved in the sexual
misconduct do it right and to be clear
so the person that was accused of this
who was a colleague of yours although
you didn't know did not know him he was
accused of of having relations with a
student but consensual if I'm not
mistaken there were two there were two
sets of complaints and one was that he'd
gone out drinking with a student one
night and they ended up sleeping in this
same bed but they didn't have sex there
was no indication that they had sex but
he was accused of possibly having come
onto her he bought her drinks and then
there was a second situation which I
actually did not write about where he'd
had a relationship with a student so I
wrote about seven or eight words about
that second relationship and that was I
think the basis of the complaints that
I'd made reference to this situation
that that in effect they felt you were
defending him
correct I suppose so you know I can't
say what anybody
thought or felt really right I guess I
guess I can but I think I think we can
surmise that that's what they thought
yeah that you really but your feelings
on on that specific matter outside of
title nine really is that these are if
they're consenting adults whether he's a
professor and she's a student that
you're okay with that basically right um
I in the first essay I was somewhat
mocking these new regulations that
govern professor student dating the
prohibited at particularly in the case
of undergrads it was sort of okay if
you're a grad student
but frowned on and when I was one of the
things I was saying was that you know
you can look around any campus on the
country who can barely throw a stone
without hitting a couple a married
couple often with children that started
out as a professor student situation and
it's widely known in academia that you
know some percentage of your colleagues
are married to former students so it
seemed a bit hypocritical to suddenly
enact these codes that would regard
those situations as like close to some
sort of credit predators I you know I
felt that the professorial was almost
being regarded as as predators and
wigging and that you know dating was was
was ruled out and you know I don't want
to sound like some old geezer and but
when I went to school back in the good
old days
you know I we did all sorts of stuff we
partied and drank with professors it was
no big deal
people were sleeping with professor's
all over the place so the this new
climate of regulation was something I
wanted to write about from a somewhat
skeptical vantage point so so when your
mind it really was about the regulation
that they were putting on not you
weren't specifically defending or not
defending the actions of this guy which
i think is sort of where it got turned a
little bit yes yeah so I think that's
interesting I mean I the version of
feminism that I would subscribe to would
see these this climate of regulation is
not in the spirit of feminism and I
think I've used the term feminist
paternalism but I will say what happened
was that or maybe we'll get to this I
mean I ended up learning more about the
situation with this professor and right
more about it in this book so there's a
couple of chapters about these two cases
against the professor where I'd do a
close reading of the title nine reports
which I ended up having access to and so
that was very informative all right so
we will get to that for sure I think
that'll that'll sort of bring this all
together okay
but okay so now you're brought up on
these charges mm-hmm what was that like
for you I mean literally you you're
you're a professor and an author and
wrote an article yeah yeah you're using
words and now you're brought up on
charges from the government yeah well
for my institution and but you know it's
right from yours yeah I mean I was very
much in the dark you know I knew nothing
about title nine and they send you like
a letter with all these links to various
and you know informational websites and
every website has more links and more
links and you know it's like a rabbit
hole of hyperlinks that you learn
nothing from like I did not learn how I
could be charged with retaliation for
writing about someone else's situation
so it's very mystifying the the
procedures and what I've learned in
these cases when you're accused of
something for the most part you don't
find out what you're accused of you
don't know what the evidence is you
often don't know who the accusers are in
my case so I the the University hired a
team of outside investigators lawyers
from another city who flew in to conduct
an investigation they would not give me
the charges in writing we I did finally
learn who the accusers were we had a
Skype session prior to me meeting with
them but so some of the procedures are
very baffling like why won't they give
you the complaints in writing how could
that possibly be legal I mean I get the
sort of kangaroo court portion of this
and how this is all done outside of our
legal system makes to me it makes no
sense whatsoever yeah but when you're
talking to these people and then there's
lawyers coming in from out of state most
what are they talking to you about if
they are not telling you what you're
charged they ask a lot of fishing
expeditions sort of questions and as I
later talk to more people who've been
through these procedures that's the mo
is the fishing expedition question and
then things that you say particularly if
you're a male professor charged with
kind of potential misconduct anything
you say can lead to another avenue of
Investigation and so people enter these
situations they don't know what their
rights are you know so like when the
investigators said to me that I could
not record the session you don't know
where these edicts are coming from you
just know somebody who seems to be an
authority is is telling you what you can
and can't do as I say you don't know
what your rights are and you don't know
what the consequences will be if you
don't go along with it and it is the
when this is happening is the entire
administration just falling into line I
mean is there anyone at the
administration that was like you know
Laura something seems wrong here or you
need a lawyer or we should have someone
defending you or sitting with you or
you're not selling you or anything yeah
no you're not alone I think every school
makes their own procedures up in my case
you are not allowed to have a lawyer in
the session with you when I met with the
investigators I could not have a lawyer
there I did consult with a lawyer on the
phone before this but I didn't want to
spend a lot of money on this you know
how it's a bit of a cheapskate but you
know I'm if you had all the money in the
world it would still be absurd
professors are spending tens of
thousands of dollars when you know
accused of something like having
improper eye contact I mean some of the
charges are so out there but I've talked
to people who have I mean just spent
vast amounts of money consulting with
lawyers but because of course now
there's a huge industry legal industry
and defending people caught in these
situations you know it's a huge growth
industry right okay so how did your case
get to pollution how did it had it wrap
itself oh well it went on for 72 days I
met with these people who'd flown in the
investigators for three hours or so I
was allowed to have a support person in
the room with me and I asked the guy who
is the head of the Faculty Senate at the
time to be my support person which was
not good because for him because he
later got brought up until nine
complaints himself for speaking out at
the Faculty Senate because he thought
that you know what it happened was a
violation of academic freedom and then
through that so he sits there with you
then defends you in another form and
then he gets brought up on yes did I get
ya fully badly that is right but what
you asked before about the
administration I mean I didn't know who
did know or who didn't know I was told
to keep this stuff confidential so um it
would it was just very unclear to me
what position I was in when I got this
letter about the charges yeah and then
not only that but then you have a
colleague offering counsel and then he
so the the chill effect around this
thing it's like why would anyone put
their butt on the line to defend you and
free speech or defend a professor's
ability to teach the way they want if
they know that they're gonna be the next
one because the preponderance of
evidence is so low that they're gonna be
the next one cause see in my situation I
did not feel like my job was at risk I
didn't have enough paranoia about the
situation to think that my university
would actually fire me for writing an
essay I thought that that would be look
very bad for them so I felt somewhat I
didn't know what the outcome was going
to be but I didn't think it was going to
be that I will lose my job whereas if I
was a guy a male professor you know or a
student for sure but a male professor
accused of something that veered more
toward sexual misconduct I would be far
more I would have been far more worrying
in this situation and I should just say
that like milk professors in teaching
situations that involve more personal
contact with students like say a dance
instructor or drama people or even music
where you might touch a student those
people are hugely at risk and I've heard
about so many cases like that where
something that once would have seemed
innocuous is now being charged as sexual
misconduct or creating a hostile
environment for student putting the
legal part of this aside for a second
what do you think this is doing to the
professor's so I get it if you're
talking about a dance professor or an
art teacher that
may touch somebody as they lean over or
whatever it is but from those people all
the way to just the regular professor
that might fear that if there's a
student that comes into their office and
they say something or only or as you
said looks at them really what do you
think this is actually doing to academia
in general right now I think the word is
starting to get out that professors are
really at risk of losing their jobs if
there's any kind of controversy with a
student and people may not know that
something like half the profits all
right now is not tenured meaning you
know or tenure Stream meaning there's no
job security about half of professors
now are kind of contract employees this
is it's the casualization of academic
labor no I didn't know that so you mean
not even on the track yeah yeah no
they're hired astad junks or instructors
on renewable contracts sometimes
one-year contracts and those people if
they get caught in a situation where
student says that professors said
something in a class that makes them
uncomfortable those people are out even
if they're found not guilty they are
likely not going to be renewed or if I
there was a case just recently there's a
school of the Chicago Art Institute with
a guy was an art history professor whose
students accused him of some students
accused him of like a textbook that he
used they thought was racist and it was
a book about comic book history and the
history of that period is of you know
about like racial imagery so it was a
book that was discussed discussing
racism in the history of clinics
incredible so you know there's such a
menace I think just are so fearful of
getting caught in these situations that
they're very becoming very self
censoring not teaching controversial
subjects being very very careful about
interactions with students and I think
also more and more male professors are
really shying away from working closely
with female students because the numbers
of complaints about situations like that
have risen and I should just say look I
have said I believe any professor that
harasses us
is in some proposes some quid pro quo
arrangement like you know a [ __ ] for
a grade I mean those people should be
fired I you know they should be out
there should be no toleration for that
well it's this sense of a student
feeling uncomfortable in class about
something somebody has said those sorts
of cases I think are really just growing
incredibly right and at the same time
just lowering the burden of proof in
general yeah also just a horrific yeah
precedent to say yeah and because all
this happens behind closed doors there's
no oversight and I think a lot of people
in the title nine field now have gotten
a bit on the how inflated with a sense
of power because there are no there are
no checks and balances there's no
oversight and so they are enlarging
their sense of what sexual misconduct is
on account of capricious ad hoc basis
you know so it's very much up to
individual title nine officers or in the
case of undergrads like student Dean's
to decide what comprises an offense and
so I don't think that there's more
sexual misconduct and going on I think
what's defined as sexual misconduct is
just like exponentially increasing yeah
and that's what I want people to
understand if they take away anything
from this is that this system created a
secondary legal system in effect yeah I
mean that is simply not how the United
States operates it is people don't know
this again I mean I feel like in my book
I sort of was breaking news about the
extent of this because until it goes to
civil cases there's just no knowledge
about what's going on and it sounds like
it would be almost impossible to get
that knowledge out yeah because of the
ridiculous system where it seems like
nobody's accountable and you're not
allowed to talk to people you don't know
what you've been brought up on how do
you get this information out yeah and
and not every professor is gonna be as
forward as you and okay with still
saying what they think and coming on
shows like this and talking about it and
all that yeah I think only two
professors so far other than myself have
gone public about cases against them
because people are terrified of speaking
out and in fact are threatened that if
they speak out they'll be charged with
retaliation and just in terms of title
nine generally there's no aggregated you
know set of data about these cases I
think we have no knowledge of how many
cases are what the content of them is
except for the cases that have gone to
civil court or settlements paid by
insurers there's some data about the
cases by insurance companies
so that's fascinating so you don't even
know how many not only how many cases
there are but how many other people
might be in your circumstance so not
people that have been accused of
anything in terms of doing an action or
having an inappropriate relationship
with a student or any of that there
could be literally five hundred other
people like you that just wrote
something in a vague defense of a
faculty member or of a take down of
title nine that could be in your
situation and you just simply have no
idea it's incredible well so i think
that i mean i weirdly have become a kind
of data central by the virtue of people
emailing me about their cases so I mean
I have an email inbox file of cases that
I don't think there is other information
about and I don't exactly and I included
some of them in unwanted advances I have
a chapter called [ __ ] confidentiality or
their little Asterix they are where I
try to anonymize is that how you say it
um but going to as no as much detail as
I can about some of the bizarre cases
people have written to me about because
after I did go public about my case I'm
not sure if I said you know I just got
all of these emails from people about
their cases and I just wouldn't say that
what when I got this email saying I was
brought up on the these complaints I had
no idea if there were other professors
who've been charged over an article I
didn't know if this was a test case
where you know it would expand the
boundaries of title 9 so I was just in
the dark and I didn't know who to talk
to or to ask about it it's so
interesting to me because I
had a series of guests on this show that
have been in similar situations either
in academia or elsewhere people that
have been put in situations where they
suddenly have to step into sort of a new
light brett Weinstein who I'm sure
you're familiar with from Evergreen
State okay yeah Jordan Peterson up in
Canada dealing with this even James
d'amour from google I mean just people
that are just saying what they think and
then suddenly are thrust into the
spotlight in a different way so shifting
a little bit so then when when Betsy
DeVos last month basically said we're
gonna we're gonna turn back these Obama
era regulations you must have found this
quite rewarding or vindicating or what's
another adjective I should use that
afflicted her you can say well not I
mean you know I'm conflicted in that I
am NOT a person who wants to have
anything positive to say about the Trump
administration I mean I you know don't
want anything to do with these people
but I did think two votes was doing what
anybody with you know would do in that
situation which was to turn back what
had happened under the Obama guidelines
I'm not sure it's gonna make any
difference on campus I mean there's been
many many you know presidents tell nine
officers people in positions of power
have already said nothing is going to
change on our campus to reassure the the
title nine activists that's actually
crazy though so the government you know
I'm not for all of these edicts that
only the executive branch makes but in
effect and that's what Obama did now
Trump reverses them okay yeah but you're
saying that the schools now because it's
sort of like a hostage situation where
they can't you know if they've made it
sound like this is the way it's supposed
to be and this is what's right they
can't kind of backtrack on it so they're
gonna keep in place basically is what
you're saying
well I think here in California I'm
pretty sure Janet Napolitano is the
Chancellor president of the UC system
has announced that wow I didn't know
that yeah that's incredible yeah yeah to
show that they're on the right side of
things so I don't know what are the
things that's happened is that the
there's been this incredible bloating of
the administrative levels layers in
universities and these people are
running the plays and
there is such a vast infrastructure
that's been put in place you can't just
dismantle that overnight so I think part
of the mission creep of all of this is
that there's um there are so many people
whose jobs it is to weed out misconduct
and prosecuted to adjudicate it that
that's not going away you know so so I'm
not optimistic that the Devoe's
guidelines even though they are saying
they're gonna have this advice and
consent or advice and notice whatever it
is period that didn't happen with Obama
under the Obama administration they're
trying to do it more procedurally this
time around but in any case I don't see
that it's gonna filter down to the
campus level yeah that's incredible so
how how could it I mean if you add if
you were in charge right now if you were
you know if you had divorces here or
Trump's here or whatever it is what
would you tell them that actually needs
to be done if this if just removing
these additions isn't enough I actually
think that I don't maybe a cynic that
what's going to happen is it more and
more cases go to civil court and will be
decided against the universities and
that the general counsel's office in the
universities are going to start
overseeing what's happening more than
they are so it's civil court judges that
are looking at these cases and saying
are you kidding can I just briefly talk
about a case that's a really interesting
one that came out of Brandeis because
what was interesting I mean most of
these situations the undergrad level are
heterosexual but this was two guys and
two guys who are in a relationship and
then broke up and sort of six months
later one of the guys said that the
other guy had kissed him while he was
sleeping
and that that was non-consensual sex
because he hadn't consented to be kissed
while you're sleeping
so Brandeis appointed some sort of
special examiner this was a title now in
charge of them and the special examiner
said yes the kisser was guilty of
non-consensual sex because the other
person hadn't consented they kicked him
out of school so these are the kinds of
cases that are one you know time
mission creep or overreach so the
students sued the sued Brandeis and you
know you have to have a lot of money to
sue a university it cost something like
a hundred grand and up to a million
dollars if a case goes to trial so this
went to a judge and the judge said you
know are you kidding your this is what
you're calling sexual assault and found
against you know the against Brandeis I
may be getting some of the details wrong
whether it was simply dismissed or there
was a judgment against Brandeis but so
it's the judges that I think are going
to be creating that level of oversight
and turning back these cases and I think
that might filter down particularly as
schools are starting to pay out
settlements to accuse students yeah
that's incredible because for me
personally I'm not someone that would
want it you know I think we have way too
much over litigation here but in effect
what you're saying is the only way to
really combat this is you need students
who've been improperly accused that have
the resources to start bringing lawsuits
because eventually the schools will
realize we can't sustain this where
we're taking so many cases that actually
don't hold without water and we can't
keep doing this and professors as well
and I think there are a few I've heard
about some cases that prefer professors
who've been dismissed are suing
universities too but they haven't got
has gotten as much attention so I do
think this is gonna be played out in the
courts for quite some time so is there a
piece of this that's sort of obvious
that I'm missing here how does this not
get to Criminal Court if there was a
case where it really involved not just a
kiss in the sleeping but if there was a
case that really involved rape or yeah
or being drugged or any of that how is
that not automatically a criminal
offense how does that even stay within
the jurisdiction of this yes doesn't
even make sense to well you know one of
the reasons that these guidelines and
these processes moved to campus is that
at the the legal level you know District
Attorney's weren't taking these cases to
trial because in a lot of these
situations there isn't evidence the
person the accuser comes forward much
later you know
so they either on an evidence level or
whatever don't rise to the legal level
so they were prosecuted on campus
because you know there was a lag or gap
in in you know the legal systems dealing
with sexual assault so I understand that
or it would take you know years for a
case to go forward so part of the issue
was to have a process in place that
would rectify what wasn't happening off
campus to get these students if there
were aggressive you know usually male
undergrads you know particularly serial
offenders you know get them off campus
so this was some of the reasons that it
wasn't handled at the criminal level so
I suspect that you found some strange
allies in this space because here I am I
don't know if I qualify the strange ally
may may be possibly but but basically
you're you're a lefty right you're you
consider yourself progressive or if you
had to describe your your political
views I called myself throughout the
book a leftist feminist I mean I wanted
to make it clear that I you know I
wanted to make that clear yeah yeah I
have not shifted right okay so well
first off what is a leftist feminists
mean to you I guess let's define that
middle yeah I mean I one point I suppose
in in my career would have called myself
a Marxist feminist so I mean it means
for me you know I believe in
redistribution and I believe in a sort
of feminism I mean I guess I was steeped
on what would have been called Marxist
feminism or materialist feminism that
took and also but that had a kind of
emancipatory direction I mean and I'm
also somebody very interested in
psychoanalysis so I use the
psychoanalysis a lot so I mean it's a
bit of a motley collection of influences
but I left I mean I mean that I think
the economic level is um something that
I want to factor in issues about class I
got I wrote a book about pornography a
long time ago that I got interested in
the subjects had written about hustler
magazine and that my point was that the
feminist anti-pornography movement had
not taken class into consideration at
all and that hustler was not just about
gender
it was also about class and a sort of
attack on elites so I'm kind of trying
to factor those levels into the sort of
you know thinking that I do yeah so I'm
curious so as a leftist feminist then
potentially or a formerly Marxist
feminist I haven't heard that one before
but all right there we go
do you find that your allies right now
are coming from quarters that don't
quite make sense to you yes the the
situation I mean I should just say the
situation on campus makes no sense in
terms of who what groups think of
themselves as on the left and I'm sort
of dubious about whether a lot of the
activism is what I would call left-wing
even though you know the right loves to
hammer the the left-leaning students but
I mean the student student activists are
more and more acting like authoritarians
and you weirdly have the conservatives
and libertarians acting like liberals
and you know promoting free speech and
and that sort of thing so this is this
is now you're telling me my light story
yeah yeah well that's because it's my
life story too in trying to myself make
sense of this political moment and yes
finding myself getting a lot of invites
from places like you know various
libertarian and conservative leaning
foundations that I do you know would not
really have had much to say to
previously
yeah how does that feel for you you know
like when you're getting invited to
these things that previously you either
would have had major political
disagreements I mean I'm guessing
especially if they're libertarian groups
they're never telling you what you can
say or anything like that nice yeah
thank you probably wouldn't go to a
place yeah that would anyway but that
you have these new allies must be kind
of weird for you I mean I know what this
feeling is that's why I'm curious yeah
it is and I mean so there's an area that
we overlap we're in agreement about but
you know I think it is more the economic
issues I mean like I did an interview
with Reason magazine they collapse
Gillespie who you know it's a really
smart interesting guy knows a lot of
social theory but you know I suppose if
we started talking about more economic
issues you know I'm not somebody who
wants to let the
or people starve you know so we're I
think that's probably where I depart you
know yes we agree on free speech we're
probably less in agreement about you
know regulation that sort of thing I
don't know that they want to let the
poor people start but they just don't
wanna so the government involve that but
that's uh that's a whole other topic but
I just think it's interesting because as
someone with those beliefs which I fully
respect I think you're finding the
allies that I've found lately is is
anyone on the Left defending you I mean
is there has been has there been any
outreach of leftist professors or
anything on there's I think there's some
well that should be your intellectual
allies right the people that agree with
you on everything that you write about
yeah I'm at a teach about are they
offering you any shelter yeah that's I
guess well I get a lot of supportive
email from people saying I would be
afraid to say what you're saying in
public so I know that there's like an
underground layer of support and I mean
I think that it's generational some of
the sort of older generation of leftists
somebody like Todd Gitlin who is you
know an SDS first any teaches at
Columbia is written also about the free
speech issues on campus so there's
certain people out there but it's no
it's been a little I'm not gonna say
lonely but I I feel somewhat on my own
in trying to make sense of this
situation and you know doing a better
job of it do you think it's possible
that your what should be your allies
especially in the public space I was
mentioning to you before in the green
room that I see all these celebrities
and comedians that when DeVos did this
stuff and rescinded these Obama era
editions that basically they were all
tweeting about how divorce and Trump or
Pro rape and they hate women and all
these these are these are leftists who
you probably agree with on all on all
the economic stuff all the social stuff
all of that stuff but they're doing you
actually an incredible disservice is
what I would say and I looped you in on
one tweet when Chelsea Handler tweeted
something about this and I said I'd love
to have you on come on with Lawrence
that's no I would shoot myself right but
think about that I mean that's that's
actually kind of fast
I would guess that if you and Chelsea
sat down about most political issues you
would agree on most things but then they
tweet these kind of crazy over-the-top
things and then they're actually
undercutting what their academic allies
should be doing I think it's a really
fascinating little piece of this I have
a sort of allergy to self-righteousness
and you know I mentioned having written
about hustler magazine and I suppose
it's what drew me to somebody like Larry
Flynt is an interesting figure you know
I was kind of interested to sort of
weave through the over-the-top
outrageous stuff he said and to try to
make sense of some of the politics
behind what he was saying
and this sort of instant position taking
that people like that are engaged in I
mean you're talking about Chelsea
Handler you know I I'm not somebody who
ever really wanted to be a pundit I
wanted to sit and think about some of
these issues and think about the
contradictions and the complications and
that's what I've tried to do in in my
writing and I think there's well this
may be sound sound the
self-congratulatory I think there's too
little of that and it may have something
to do with Twitter and you know the you
know sort of instantaneous opinion
forming that is required of people who
are in Twitter but I don't think it's
interesting and so I guess I'm kind of
veered toward the people who are saying
things that complicate this situation as
opposed to simplify it yeah well that's
why we're here doing this so that we
could get some of that across yeah all
right let's talk a little bit about your
book what's the exact quote that you
have on the front of the book I have it
here somewhere but it's it's pretty
perfect about feminism if this feminism
hijacked by melodrama yeah this is
feminism is feminism a hijacked by my
mom yeah yeah that's good that you know
that that was that was a very on the
spot question but you are correct so
what what is happening to feminism there
there I see from my audience and just
from so many people that I respect in
the public space right now just an
abject rejection of modern feminism
these are not people who dislike women
these are people who want equality of
opportunity these are people who date
and sometime
our women in the first place so I don't
think it's about hating women in any way
but that modern feminism has just been
morphed into something sort of crazy
how's that for an opening it's a broad
question so take what that wasn't a fun
good it's a bit hard to answer that you
know here's where my Freudian side kicks
in I mean I feel that in the current
situation in relation to these questions
about sexual assault or what's going on
in campus in terms of sexual politics I
do feel that there's been too little
self scrutiny on the part of women who
regard themselves as feminists as
opposed to the scrutiny of like male
sexuality male aggressivity and it was
one of the things and this is probably
one of the more controversial sections
of the book where I tried to write about
how much drunken sex binge drinking you
know could condition sex there is on
campus and how much you know women are
reluctant to analyze their own
participation in these situations or our
own conflicts about sexuality so you
know that's something where again I was
kind of trying to complicate the
situation as opposed to just say men are
predators you know male sexuality is
aggressive and bad and women are these
sort of violated innocence so I feel
like there's just too little I'm maybe
not saying this incredibly well but you
know I think like too little
introspection about our own sexual sort
of participation right so even though to
write about that or talk about that I
know that there's going to be a certain
amount of people will say well you're
victim-blaming
yeah that they're already going to put
the onus on you even though you're just
you're really talking about personal
accountability to some degree yeah I
mean you know if somebody's using force
against you that's not a situation where
one needs to talk about personal
accountability but in terms of drinking
and the kind of complicities that arise
in in those situations and the ways that
I think you know I'm a teacher and I
think
University should be in the business of
educating students and helping them
figure out how to be more autonomous how
to be more self examining as opposed to
this layer of regulation that you know
it has taken the place of education so
that's what I'd like to see more of you
know and I think self-examination honest
discussions about what happens in these
sexual situations and alcohol-fueled
situations so you know I'm kind of
pragmatic about it yeah I mean speaking
of pragmatic how much do you think just
social media in general has affected
this whole conversation because I would
imagine that a lot of times some of
these cases are brought up because the
next day when when they wake up hungover
and everything they suddenly realize
there's five pictures of them doing
crazy things you know do mean drinking
and a funnel in their mouth and taking
bong hits or whatever they're doing and
I think back to my college days I mean I
did pretty much everything you could
think of the idea that now everyone's
walking around with cameras doing all
these things it just it's almost like
they're creating like a hostage
situation but they're the guards and the
hostages at the time yeah I think that's
really true and it's something I spent a
long time and about a year trying to
have conversations with my own students
about this issue of sexual assault and
what was really happening and I found
out a lot of distressing things I mean
particularly distressing if you've been
a feminist for quite some time and think
by this point in the evolution of human
history women should not have such a
hard time saying no or knowing what they
want in these in these situations and
you know I found out I think that a lot
of the drinking has to do with
particularly on the part of women not
really knowing what they want and so
drinking themselves a lot also is not to
actually have to decide in situations
you know yes or no do you think that's
more uniquely a female trading I it may
be you know I had an interesting
conversation with Susie about the sex
activists who said that she works with
college students a lot who many most of
whom have never had sex Ober and are
appalled at the thought that you would
even try to do that but when is a
ridiculous
thing to do sober I think it would
actually seem but what I was going to
say about the social media part so I I
in talking with students and I had a
conversation with a class one of my
classes once were and I repeat this in
the book where somebody said something
like I would they were they were
moralizing about a movie that I'd shown
and about the sexual choices one of the
characters had made and they're
moralizing you know just seemed I wanted
to sort of puncture it a bit so I said
something like you know when I was in
school we all thought about we talked
about liberation and you know sex is
pleasurable you guys seem to think about
sex is just simply a harm and a
potentially destructive thing and I feel
kind of sorry for you and one of the
students said well yeah sex can kill you
so I started thinking that well this was
this generation that was the first post
aids post HIV generation they've all had
this you know god-awful forms of sex
education where the destructive harmful
sides of sex have been emphasized to
them but I talked to the student who
said this he'd graduated we had an email
conversation and what he said was what I
meant was social death that social media
like everybody knows what you did the
night before and you can be sort of
killed publicly because of these these
choices that you've made so I do think
there's something about them feeling
like they're in a kind of fish ball that
that does change the the tenor or the
sense of the experience of it and and I
think this you know the after the
regrets in the aftermath or the feeling
that you know many months later well
wait I didn't actually consent to that I
think social media does have something
to do with the the way these the ways
these situations are construed later as
harmful we're in the you know president
in a moment that they happened you know
it was just a sense of confusion yeah so
that's really interesting so basically
it's a compounding of really poor sex
education in general or or just
attaching a certain amount of fear which
may at one time
been justified and then you add the
social media now you really got like
this this toxic mess there yeah and the
other thing is that I think there are
just a lot of messages on campus aimed
at women I mean everywhere you go the
conversation is about assault so I think
there's an I mean almost a kind of
encouragement to frame experiences as
having been assaulted or non-consensual
after the fact yeah so that all seems
very consistent with something that I
see on the left lately that we've talked
a lot about here that the left at least
right now seems to really value
victimhood
they think that victimhood is virtue so
it sort of makes sense you you can't
talk about sexuality in a way that's
empowering you have to talk about it in
a way that creates a victim situation
for you because then you have sort of
authority to talk about it do you think
that that's a fair I would step back
from that a little bit and say that you
know I I think the attention to social
justice on campus is a valuable thing so
I you know I do want to say there have
been people I mean there's you know who
are more marginalized who are victimized
whose identities have been have
subjected them to various forms of
violence so the UM I dislike the
language of victimization you know
getting as broad as that at the same
time there is a way that those positions
them you know and it comes under the
rubric of identity politics let's say
you know that the identities that have
been have been marginalized I mean do
you attract a lot of attention you know
both in the curriculum and not in the
curriculum to some degree to rectify you
know those sort of you know errors of
history in the past but you know so that
does play into all of these things sort
of I think converge around this notion
of sexual victimization at the moment
including you know than this this layer
that comes down from the did come down
from the federal government in the form
of title 9 yeah so how do you
unfurl all that I mean how do you as a
feminist take the power back now do you
see a movement growing on there I
haven't really seen it I hope it's there
well I do hope that you know if this
doesn't sound grandiose at the book that
I wrote it will have some effect and you
know what I was able to do was um I got
access to to title nine reports about
this professor and I man was in receipt
of a lot of other actual timeline
reports from people who sent me both
professors and students who sent me the
the documents from their cases so I went
through using all the critical skills
that I've developed in my many years as
a leftist feminist and you know you know
kind of close analysis of the sort of
decisions that the title nine officers
were making in this case and I talked
about how capricious the the judgments
were how gender biased
you know how steeped in stereotypes
about male and female sexuality they
were so you know that's something that
there hasn't been an opportunity to do
to look at how these judgments are being
made and and and to contest them because
as you know I've said all of this has
happened in in behind closed doors
there's been no oversight no daylight no
transparency so I think more
transparency on the this process and I
also think transparency or discussion
about sex on campus and particularly
heterosexual relations generally that
needs to happen yeah
but basically you're saying if you were
a young professor these days you
probably wouldn't want to teach in the
California system knowing that they're
gonna keep a lot of this stuff in place
yeah you'd rather go somewhere else
where you're not gonna have to just deal
with it pretty in effect you know I
don't think people have all the
opportunities in the world it's not like
you can vote with your feet you know
when you're in a bad job market which
you know academia now is quite a bad job
market I don't think it's something
people generally do I tend to do like
when you're offered a job somewhere to
look at the title 9 pie
you know I'm not sure that's happening
yeah let's talk about some of your other
academic interests what's exciting you
these days we can move on from title 9
for a moment yeah I think I'm still kind
of figuring out this you know we haven't
gotten caught up in this in this
situation and you know here we are
talking about policy issues I'm not at
somebody who ever saw myself as a policy
person I mean I'm very interested in
writing and issues of style and I've
said that one of the things that
happened to me in writing this first
Chronicle as it was I have a lot of envy
of writers like somebody like Philip
Roth who feels a lot of freedom on on
the page and I wrote a book a number of
years ago called against love a polemic
which is a sort of attack on on monogamy
and talking about the elephant in the
room and long-term coupledom which is
the fact that sexual desire often
doesn't persist as long as you know a
long-term 30-year marriage does so and
that was a book where I found myself
feeling a lot of freedom on the page to
to like figure out all the metaphors
about monogamy and you know it's like a
premature grave and so in fact what
interests me is that like figuring out a
level of freedom stylistically in the
stuff that I write about so policy
discussions it's not does not really
lend itself to to that am I good at it
you may not love it but I mean you know
what you're talking about this obviously
at least in this case it's very personal
to you so you know is it out I mean it
you know it's this has been an
interesting experience for me
because I did feel like I was sort of
called on to kind of step up and say
things publicly that might be
controversial and risk whatever sort of
repercussions might come but it didn't
make me interested in issues about
democracy you know and the American
tradition and I've tried to learn more
about stuff like due process and why
it's important so something about the
the
voice of American writing you know from
people like Melville or Twain and
Huckleberry Finn and and the sort of
freedom on the page that American
writers have felt that I feel like I
have borrowed from him in my own work
there's some way that I think that has
my thinking about being a writer has
changed somewhat by being finding myself
in this situation of being accused of
things and having to take a public
position about freedoms and rights it
was a bit of a convoluted and although
but I get it I mean it's interesting
because as a professor you should have
the ability and the freedom to not only
teach what you want in your in your
class but also to be writing about the
things that you want so really you're
just asking for the for the things that
in some way you probably have already
yeah I went to art school
and started out as a visual artist and
then a video artist so I'm not a
traditional academic and I just the
other night had the chance to speak at
my alma mater San Francisco Art
Institute and realized how much of being
part of or being schooled in a kind of
avant-garde tradition that did have to
do with pushing back against social
proprieties and an aesthetic norms like
how much that's influenced my work so
even in writing about this wonky thing
title 9 I find myself kind of wanting to
take those liberties that are both part
of this artistic tradition but also like
this American the freedom you know
something like Walt Whitman I mean who's
the most known for expressing a kind of
sense of America as a sense of personal
possibility and liberty in terms of
writing and voice you know so to
incorporate all of those that history in
that tradition you know in my work so I
know that sounds weird and and
highfalutin though but it's what's been
on my mind after having gone through
this whole thing yeah so I've only got
one more for you nice a nice segue of
that which is what would you say to the
other professors students administrators
all of the people that that see some of
the nonsense that you've had to deal
with that are just afraid to talk I get
so many emails
people I'm afraid to post your Facebook
clips I'm afraid to say this my brother
won't talk to me anymore all of that
stuff as someone that now is on the
other side as so many of my guests have
been they've staked out some position
and they were afraid probably lost some
friends didn't get support in ways that
they wanted but then made it to the
other side as someone that has done that
or at least is in the process of that
what's the best thing that you could say
to those people I think there's two
levels of fear you know there's a fear
of social you know disapproval that
happens on Twitter or social media and
that I would just like don't even think
about that but there are real material
fears like the fear of losing your job
and your health insurance and you know
possibly your house when you can't meet
your mortgage payment so I think what I
try to do in my own situation was to
separate out the real fears from the
those other fears you know the fear of
people disapproving of what I would say
so I did try to think very seriously
about was I likely to lose my job if I
wrote about the title 9 process and I
decided that no it wasn't a realistic
fear I did not think my university would
fire me and that turned out to be true
and you know could I live with being
disapproved of on Twitter well yes so I
think that it's about not you know it's
about avoiding paranoia and you know and
and being realistic and taking realistic
risks so I do think that's what I did I
tried to kind of separate out what was
an acceptable level of risk and what
wouldn't be an acceptable level of risk
if I didn't have tenure and would be
likely to lose my job maybe that would
be not an acceptable level of risk yeah
well I'd say I thoroughly enjoyed this I
mean this is what it's all about to me
people that are having an honest
conversation that sometimes get thrust
into a conversation without having
wanted it in the first place but then
use it for something else no I wish you
luck on this adventure we should do this
again and we'll do it in you know maybe
a year or so or who knows what'll happen
in the next year but we should do it
again and just sort of get an update on
this and see if some of this stuff
actually if some of the brush has been
cleared and maybe people are thinking
about this a little more I would love to
actively
all right and you guys can find out more
about Laura and her work in her books
and all that good stuff at Laura Kipnis
[Music]
you